face à l'accélération de la crise
ukrainienne la flambée des prix du
pétrole amorcé depuis quelques jours et
est inévitable le baril de brent flirte
désormais avec les 100 dollars un record
qui date de juillet 2014 à l'époque où
la russie 3e producteur mondial de
pétrole avaient déjà été frappées de
sanctions pour son annexion de la crimée
looking back up twenty four qui nous
regarde ce qu'il s'est passé en 2014
nous n'avons pas fait assez en tant
qu'européens nous libérer de la
dépendance aux hydrocarbures russes
pétrole
premier exportateur mondial de gaz
naturel la russie fournit près de la
moitié du gaz consommé en europe la
tendance à la hausse des prix devrait
donc se confirmer après l annonce par le
chancelier allemand de la non
certification du gazoduc nord stream 2
qui devait doubler l'acheminement du gaz
russe le long de la mer baltique
sanction des occidentaux mais aussi
possibilité pour moscou de couper le
robinet les différents scénarios laisse
penser que la crise énergétique n'en est
qu'à son commencement et ce malgré les
discours du ministre russe de l'énergie
présent au forum des pays exportateurs
de gaz organisée au qatar
la fédération de russie veut affirmer
son engagement à exporter le gaz naturel
sans interruption le qatar lui affirme
pouvoir réorienter entre 10 et 15% de sa
production gazière a priori insuffisant
pour compenser l'impact de la crise les
factures à la pompe et du gaz devrait
donc un peu plus s'alourdir pour le
consommateur et les marchés anticipant
les sanctions contre la russie ont
commencé à chuter dès lundi à moscou la
bourse était toujours à la baisse ce
mardi après avoir déjà perdu 6% la
veille